it's Sunday November 14th 1965 US combat
troops have been in South Vietnam for
just eight months Army lieutenant
colonel Hal Moore and his battalion have
their orders seek out and kill communist
forces here in the Central Highlands I
[Music]
had very little information on the enemy
very little intelligence information but
I knew that the enemy had been
retreating into the Lladro Valley
Colonel Moore's foray into the ayah
Drang River Valley will ramp up u.s.
involvement in Vietnam and set the stage
for years of bloody conflict it takes
shape in the early 60s under President
John F Kennedy they think the Vietnamese
people and ourselves agree we want the
Communists to be contained and the
Americans to kill halt but we are not
there to see a war lost the United
States sends weapons and builds military
bases in South Vietnam to fend off the
forces of the Communist leader Ho Chi
Minh in the north
pose guerrilla fighters in the south the
Vietcong use violence and terror to
undermine the government Howe is
determined to unite North and South
Vietnam under his communist rule on
November 1st 1963 South Vietnamese
military leaders staged a coup and
assassinate President ZM the Kennedy
administration not only supports but
encourages the cool
now responsibility for South Vietnam
destiny rests squarely on the shoulders
of the United States
[Music]
tensions come to a head on August 2nd
1964 when North Vietnamese patrol boats
attacked this US destroyer the Maddox in
the Tonkin Gulf Johnson seizes the
opportunity and gets Congress to pass a
resolution authorizing him to undertake
military action within months Vietcong
guerillas begin attacking the US air
bases
[Music]
on March 2nd 1965 President Johnson ups
the ante the u.s. launches an intense
and long term bombing campaign against
North Vietnam called Operation Rolling
Thunder
army general william Westmoreland the US
commander in Vietnam receives the
president's approval to call up two
battalions of Marines from the States
on March 8 1965 these Marines come
ashore near Danae and fortify the
perimeter of the
orders to seek out the Vietcong and kill
them
we'll define America's expanding mission
eight months later this strategy brings
Lieutenant Colonel Hal Moore and his men
to the aya Drang Valley ninety minutes
after landing they face 1,500 no feet
from these soldiers the men establish a
perimeter and battle to protect their
landing zone
if the enemy gains control of the
clearing Moore and his men have little
chance of survival
on the dawn of the second morning
economists refocuses strike on the
seventh section of the landing zone the
attack decimates to us platoons 42
Americans perish in less than three
hours
[Music]
in the badlands the US forces abandoned
the landing zone
their goal was never to occupy the area
but to kill as many enemy forces as they
could and leave with an estimated 1,800
North Vietnamese soldiers dead the US
Army declares the Battle of victory
but what had been a limited conflict
with guerrilla fighters in the south is
about to escalate into a broader
conflict with North Vietnam
for these soldiers on the front lines
the stakes are much higher and their
mission and far more deadly
you